During the 19th century, there were many freed
slaves that went on to lead extremely noteworthy
lives despite all the adversity they faced
in their lifetime, such as the world famous
Frederick Douglass, who not only played an
important role in fighting for black people’s
rights, but also championed women’s rights,
particularly playing an important part in
the fight for the right for women to vote.
Not everyone can be so accomplished as the
great Frederick Douglas, but that doesn’t
mean they don’t at times do noteworthy things.
This brings us to the subject of today- one
Jordan Anderson, a former slave who received
a letter from his former master requesting
he come back to work.
Jordan’s reply was a deliciously satirical
letter in which, when reading between the
lines, he essentially told him in the most
polite and eloquent way possible to kiss his
derriere.
Widely published throughout the United States
and parts of Europe, the response made Jordan
a media darling overnight.
Given his background as a slave, we unsurprisingly
know very little about Jordan’s life prior
to being taken from his parents and sold as
a boy.
What little historians have managed to piece
together is that Anderson was born in December
of 1825 “somewhere” in Tennessee.
In fact, we know so little about Jordan that
we’re not even sure if that’s how he actually
spelled his first name, since it’s written
as “Jourdan” on some documents, such as
an 1870 federal census of Dayton Ohio where
he lived at the time, and “Jordan” on
others.
This said, historians are confident that Jordan
was sold into slavery at around age 7 or 8
to one General Paulding Anderson.
Anderson then took Jordan and gifted him to
his son, Patrick, who went by his middle name,
Henry, for most of his life.
Exactly what role Jordan served during his
formative years isn’t clear, but we do know
that at the time it was common for slave owners
to give their children similarly aged slaves
to function as servants who doubled as playmates;
so it’s likely Jordan served such a function
for Henry who was around his age.
As he grew into a man, Jordan took a more
active role on the Anderson family plantation
in Big Spring, Tennessee, apparently becoming
one of Henry’s most reliable and able workers.
At an unknown point in time in 1848 while
working on the plantation, Jordan married
a fellow slave named Amanda McGregor with
whom he eventually sired 11 children.
When the American Civil War began in 1861,
Jordan’s life changed very little and he
still continued to dutifully work the plantation
for his master with his wife until one fateful
day in 1864 when Union Soldiers happened upon
the plantation.
Upon encountering Jordan, the soldiers granted
him, his wife and children their freedom,
making the act official with papers from the
Provost Marshal General of Nashville, documents
Jordan would treasure for the rest of his
life.
Upon being granted his freedom, Jordan immediately
left the plantation which angered Henry to
such an extent that he shot at Jordan as he
was leaving, only ceasing to fire when a neighbor
grabbed Henry’s pistol from him.
Reportedly, Henry vowed to kill Jordan if
he ever set foot on his property again.
Following his departure from the plantation,
Jordan worked briefly in a Nashville field
hospital, becoming close friends with a surgeon
called Dr Clarke McDermont.
When the Civil War ended in 1865, McDermont
helped Jordan and his family move to Dayton,
Ohio and put him in contact with his father-in-law,
Valentine Winters, an abolitionist who helped
him secure work in the town.
For the most part, Jordan’s life in Dayton
was uneventful, with his time spent working
with a stoic sense of quiet dignity, supporting
his family and making sure his many children
received a good education, something the illiterate
Jordan was never given the opportunity to
have.
(In fact, it was noted that while still a
slave, when an unspecified white girl tried
to teach one of his children to read, the
girl was beaten for it and forced to stop.)
Jordan’s quiet life was briefly shattered
in July of 1865 when out of the blue he received
an urgent letter from his former master, Henry.
As Jordan couldn’t read, he took the letter
to Valentine Winters and asked him to read
it to him.
As it turns out, following the Civil War,
the Anderson Plantation had fallen into complete
disrepair, as is wont to happen when your
entire workforce leaves pretty much all at
once.
Deeply in debt, in a desperate attempt to
save himself from total financial ruin, Henry
reached out to the only man he knew who not
only had the skills needed for the harvest,
but also potentially the clout to convince
some of the other slaves to return for paid
work- Jordan Anderson.
The letter also promised that Jordan would
be paid and be treated as a free man if he
returned.
At this point, most people would have screwed
up the letter and thrown it in the trash while
taking some sordid satisfaction in that karma
was doing its job, but Jordan had a better
idea.
After several days of pondering the letter’s
contents, he invited Winters to his home and
dictated an exquisite response:
Sir: I got your letter, and was glad to find
that you had not forgotten Jourdon, and that
you wanted me to come back and live with you
again, promising to do better for me than
anybody else can.
I have often felt uneasy about you.
I thought the Yankees would have hung you
long before this, for harboring Rebs they
found at your house.
I suppose they never heard about your going
to Colonel Martin’s to kill the Union soldier
that was left by his company in their stable.
Although you shot at me twice before I left
you, I did not want to hear of your being
hurt, and am glad you are still living.
It would do me good to go back to the dear
old home again, and see Miss Mary and Miss
Martha and Allen, Esther, Green, and Lee.
Give my love to them all, and tell them I
hope we will meet in the better world, if
not in this.
I would have gone back to see you all when
I was working in the Nashville Hospital, but
one of the neighbors told me that Henry intended
to shoot me if he ever got a chance.
I want to know particularly what the good
chance is you propose to give me.
I am doing tolerably well here.
I get twenty-five dollars a month, with victuals
and clothing; have a comfortable home for
Mandy,—the folks call her Mrs. Anderson,—and
the children—Milly, Jane, and Grundy—go
to school and are learning well.
The teacher says Grundy has a head for a preacher.
They go to Sunday school, and Mandy and me
attend church regularly.
We are kindly treated.
Sometimes we overhear others saying, “Them
colored people were slaves” down in Tennessee.
The children feel hurt when they hear such
remarks; but I tell them it was no disgrace
in Tennessee to belong to Colonel Anderson.
Many darkeys would have been proud, as I used
to be, to call you master.
Now if you will write and say what wages you
will give me, I will be better able to decide
whether it would be to my advantage to move
back again.
As to my freedom, which you say I can have,
there is nothing to be gained on that score,
as I got my free papers in 1864 from the Provost-Marshal-General
of the Department of Nashville.
Mandy says she would be afraid to go back
without some proof that you were disposed
to treat us justly and kindly; and we have
concluded to test your sincerity by asking
you to send us our wages for the time we served
you.
This will make us forget and forgive old scores,
and rely on your justice and friendship in
the future.
I served you faithfully for thirty-two years,
and Mandy twenty years.
At twenty-five dollars a month for me, and
two dollars a week for Mandy, our earnings
would amount to eleven thousand six hundred
and eighty dollars.
(About $178,000 today) Add to this the interest
for the time our wages have been kept back,
and deduct what you paid for our clothing,
and three doctor’s visits to me, and pulling
a tooth for Mandy, and the balance will show
what we are in justice entitled to.
Please send the money by Adams’s Express,
in care of V. Winters, Esq.,[267] Dayton,
Ohio.
If you fail to pay us for faithful labors
in the past, we can have little faith in your
promises in the future.
We trust the good Maker has opened your eyes
to the wrongs which you and your fathers have
done to me and my fathers, in making us toil
for you for generations without recompense.
Here I draw my wages every Saturday night;
but in Tennessee there was never any pay-day
for the negroes any more than for the horses
and cows.
Surely there will be a day of reckoning for
those who defraud the laborer of his hire.
In answering this letter, please state if
there would be any safety for my Milly and
Jane, who are now grown up, and both good-looking
girls.
You know how it was with poor Matilda and
Catherine.
I would rather stay here and starve—and
die, if it come to that—than have my girls
brought to shame by the violence and wickedness
of their young masters.
You will also please state if there has been
any schools opened for the colored children
in your neighborhood.
The great desire of my life now is to give
my children an education, and have them form
virtuous habits.
Say howdy to George Carter, and thank him
for taking the pistol from you when you were
shooting at me.
From your old servant,
Jourdon Anderson.
At Jordan’s behest, Winters sent the letter
to Henry with the simple, informal title,
“Letter from a Freedman to His Old Master”.
Winters later had the letter published in
an edition of the Cincinnati Commercial with
the same title.
The letter proved to be immensely popular,
both because of the sheer level of snark displayed
and the eloquence with which Jordan had told
off his former “boss”.
The letter was later reprinted in papers across
the country and even published in parts of
Europe, making Henry a world-renowned laughing
stock.
Unsurprisingly, Henry never took Jordan up
on his offer to pay him 50 years of wages
in one go and the letter likely stopped any
of his other slaves being tempted back when
he wrote to them as well.
As a result, the crops that year were never
harvested.
Henry, deeply in debt, had to sell the plantation
for a fraction of its worth and he died penniless
and destitute a few years later at age 44.
As for Jordan, he lived and worked in Dayton
for the rest of his long life, dying at the
age of 81 in 1907.